DOESN'T THINK REPEALING THE
RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS IS EVEN
POSSIBLE.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
IT WAS A WILD DAY ON WALL STREET
TODAY.
THE DATA RECORDED A SWING OF 737
POINTS.
GOING FROM WAY UP TO FINISH DOWN
345.
S&P 500 WAS UP -- OFF 46 RATHER.
THE NASDAQ PLUNGED 212.
LET'S GET SOME ANALYSIS AND A
LOOK AT OTHER BUSINESS NEWS.
DEIRDRE BOLTON OF THE
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK JOINS US
FROM NEW YORK.
A WILD DAY.
>> INDEED.
THE LAST 60 MINUTES OF THE
SESSION, STOCKS FELL HARD.
TECH STOCKS FELL THE MOST.
THEY DRAGGED THE MARKET LOWER.
UNTIL RECENTLY, TUCK WAS A
BRIGHT SPOT EVEN ON VOLATILE
DAYS.
IT WAS THE ONE PART OF THE
MARKET THAT WOULD STEADY
SENTIMENT.
THAT MAY BE OVER.
FACEBOOK AND NVIDIA ARE FACING
HIGH-PROFILE CHALLENGES AND HURT
THE ENTIRE TECH SECTOR.
FACEBOOK STOCK IS DOWN 20% FROM
ITS FEBRUARY HIGH.
THE FTC IS INVESTIGATING THE
COMPANY FOR THE SECOND TIME
SINCE ITS FOUNDING ABOUT PRIVACY
AND DATA SECURITY.
37 STATES ATTORNEYS GENERAL ARE
INVESTIGATING FACEBOOK.
COOK COUNTY, ILLINOIS, SUING THE
COMPANY.
THE LAWSUIT STATES FACEBOOK
VIOLATED STATE FRAUD LAW AND
SAYS FACEBOOK IS NOT A SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANY.
IT IS THE LARGEST DATA MINING
OPERATION IN EXISTENCE.
FOUNDER AND CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG
WILL TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS
APRIL 10.
MOST EXPERTS SAY FACEBOOK IS
SURE TO FACE FINES OR SOME FORM
OF REGULATION OR BOTH.
THIS SPECTER OF REGULATION MEANS
INVESTORS MAY NO LONGER SEE TECH
AS A SAFE INVESTMENT BUT AS A
RISKY ONE.
TWO OTHER TECH CEOs HAVE BEEN
INVITED TO TESTIFY AT THE SAME
HEARING.
GOOGLE AND TWITTER.
THE PERCEPTION OF RISK PUSHING
CHIP GIANT IN VIDEO DOWN.
IT'S CHIPS GO TO DRIVERLESS
TECH.
LASTLY, AND UBER DRIVERLESS CAR
KILLED A PEDESTRIAN IN ARIZONA.
IT IS A STEP BACK FOR WHAT THE
COMPANY BELIEVED WAS SAFE TECH.
THE STOCK PLUNGED MORE THAN 7%.
EVEN APPLE, MICROSOFT, AMAZON
ALL WERE AFFECTED.
THEY ALL CLOSED IN THE RED BY AT
LEAST 3.5%.
NASDAQ DOWN BY CLOSE TO 3%.
WIPING OUT ALMOST ALL OF
YESTERDAY'S GAINS.
CHANCES ARE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
MORE OF THIS DAY-TO-DAY MARKET
VOLATILITY.
BRET, BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: 11 PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TRYING TO BLOCK THE
$85 BILLION MERGER BETWEEN AT&T
AND TIME WARNER.
THIS TRIAL IS ONGOING.
ANYTHING NEW TONIGHT?
>> IT'S A CONSUMER DRIVEN STORY,
AS YOU KNOW.
THE ARGUMENT THAT THE GOVERNMENT
IS MAKING IS THAT THIS MERGER
WOULD BE UNFRIENDLY TO
CONSUMERS.
HAVING US ALL PAY MORE FOR OUR
DATA, OUR TABLE, EVERYTHING UP
AND USE.
OF COURSE THE LAWYERS ON AT&T